[音楽]
あなたは人生で拒絶されたことがありますかあなたが望んでいた仕事に就けなかったあなた
は
誰かがあなたにノーと言います私たちはおそらく
拒絶された経験があるでしょうそれは拒絶されるのはとても
簡単
です 離れて諦め
ますか、それとも今日
は諦めない方法について話したいのですが、機会を見つける
ために私の名前は夏目伊藤です。私は
ここ東京のクリーンテックスタートアップの1人の共同創設者です。
自分が起業家になるとは思ってもみませんでした
が、私は
それほど賢い人ではないので、どうなるのでしょうか。
これは、
ドアを開けたいと思っているドアがある場合に想像するタイプの考え方
です。 ドアを開くに
はコードを取得する必要
がありますが、コードがありません。
ボブと人間が許可された状態で40年しか経験していないという説明
があります。私の状況で
は、説明だけで拒否されますが、
このように思います。
私はただするつもりはない
彼らが実際に何を探しているのかわからないので諦めます彼ら
は非常に
意欲的または情熱的であるかリスクを冒そうとしている誰かを探しているかもしれ
ませんあなたは彼らが実際に何を探しているのかわからない
ので
私はそれを試してみます とにかく、
大学を卒業する直前の
私の話です。人生で何をしたいのか
わからなかったので、マンハッタンからオファーがありました。マンハッタンに行くことができます。
私にとって、私は
多くの異なる機会を探し続けていました、
または
あなたはある日私がフェイスブックにいたことを知っています
もちろん私はソーシャルメディアにいます
そして私はそれがバイラルになるだろうこのビデオを見つけました
この会社で働きたいと思ったのですが、調べ
てみると
、
日本のスタートアップであることがわかり
、興奮し
て数日後にすぐにメールを送ってくれました。CEOから返事が来て
、
とても興奮しました。 私は
ああ私の神のように私がこれで働くつもりだと想像していました
彼らの製品はとてもクールだと思うクールな会社
私は待ちきれませんが連絡が途絶えました
その後も彼に複数のメールを送りました
そして彼からの連絡がありません時間が
経ちました私は卒業しました私はカップルのために私の家族に会うために日本に戻ります
数週間
、私は
彼らが
ここ東京にいるので
、おそらく私がいる場所から1時間ほど離れている
ので、なぜ私は彼らに会いに行くのか
、オフィスに行ってベルを鳴らしたことを覚えて
いました。
スミイトCEOから採用面接を
受けたいのですが、女性の方からは予約はありますか？
私はとてもひどく欲しかったので
、たくさんのメールのようにたくさんのメールを送ろうとしていました。
おそらく彼は私が
彼か何かをストーカーしていると思ってい
ましたが、私は彼にもう一度メールを送りました。
私はそうではないので、採用面接のために私に会います あなたの時間を無駄にするつもりで
、私は最終的に彼からの返事を聞きました。それは
私がインターンシップとして始めて
、最終的に
私がプッシュし続けて努力し続けなければ私が
たぶん到達しなかったならこの物語のようなフルタイムになる方法です。
彼らのために働いて、私はおそらく
完全に異なる仕事をすることに
なりました、そして今日の私の人生は完全に
異なる
でしょう、あなたが本当に試したいものがあるなら
一度だけあきらめないでくださいそしてあなた
が押し続けて結果を試し続けるなら
完全に
異なっていて、人生が変わる可能性がある
ので、次に話したいの
は、あなたの機会を見つけることです。
私たちの生活の中で、私たちは毎日さまざまな機会に出会うので、
さまざまなもの
やさまざまな情報を毎日目
にし
ます。
私たちの生活の中で
、あなたの機会を見つけてそれを実現する機会はすべて同じようにありますが
、
あなたが本当に一生懸命努力し
続け
、できるだけ多くの人と話すこと
ができれば、 役に立ったし、違うかもしれない
ので、2年後に最初の
会社を辞め
たのは素晴らしいことでしたが
、
さまざまな経験を積み
、何か違うことをしたいと思っていたので、次に進む時が来たと思い
ました。 環境問題のような私たちの社会問題を助けることができます
が、もちろん
私は科学者でもエンジニアでもないのですぐに見つけるつもりはないので、
そこに何があるのか、どんな種類のものがあるのかわか
かった
ので、始めなければなりませんでした
さまざまな研究
を行い、さまざまな人々
と話をし
ました。環境関連の
テクノロジーやこれに興味があるように、または
さまざまなタイプの人々とのさまざまなイベントやネットワークに参加したように、彼らと話し始め
ました。 合計私はまだ1日を見つけることができませんでした
そしてある日私はこの男に会いました彼は最初に
私に
完全に異なる仕事をしたい
と思っていました とても
理解しづらいの
ですが、面白くてかっこいい音がするような感じでしたが、わからない
ので家に帰って勉強しました。
それについてもっと学び、それが自分が探し
ていたテクノロジーだとわかりました。
とても興奮
してすぐに彼に電話しました。
このテクノロジーを世界規模で導入したい
と彼は笑いました。
試してみるように大丈夫だと思うなら、彼は
すでに多くの人が言っていることを知っていました。
前に同じことを言ったので、
彼はおそらく笑ったので
、試してみる機会があり、
とても興奮しましたが、
同時に、
これをしないと
どうなるか、好きならどう感じるか、というプレッシャーがありました。
ネガティブな
考え
がたくさん浮かびましたが、
ネガティブであると思い始めたら、
達成できないと
思ったので、自分でできると信じなければなりません。
これを
実現さ
せるので、私はこれを手に入れました。
これを実現
し、早送りしました。 私が言ったこと、そして
誰も
が私を見始めることができる彼女は実際に
それをすることができるので、人々が私を見る方法が変わったのは初めてでした、
そして私
はあなたが本当に試したいものがあればこれらの話のように私自身で私の機会を得ました
1回か2回の
失敗や拒絶
をあきらめず、押し続けて
努力を続けてください。そうし続けると、
結果が完全に
異なり、人生が変わる可能性が
あり、機会に出会ったとき
に怖がら
ずに信じてください。 一日の終わりにあなたが信頼できる唯一の人はあなた自身であるため、あなた自身であなた自身を信頼して
ください
私はあなたが今日からそれを始めてくれることを願ってい
ます